she says what was your intent in
providing such female characters of
strength in a genre that typically
reduces women to witches wives and/or
[ __ ]
what to be fair I have my share of all
of those witches wives and [ __ ] but I
try to make them fully fleshed out a
human which is wives and Wars and as
well to introduce other things what goes
back to what I was saying earlier about
common common humanity I submit it seems
strange and I have to say this as sort
of a weirdly radical statement but women
are people and they're driven by the
same desires that that drive men I think
you know desire for respect and power
and desire to protect your children
greed for money for a claim where
everybody wants to be loved it's all
common humanity and I just try to write
my female characters as I write my male
characters you know you know I do take
into account that is a very patriarchal
society so they're they are limited to
certain roles and some of them fit
comfortably within the roles that
they're Westerosi Society has assigned
them and some of them do not fit
comfortably into those roles and
therefore encounter a certain amount of
rejection or attention or ridicule as
they as they try to pursue their own
dreams or as they frustrate their own
dreams and all this is great all this is
is conflict it's its character tension
it's it's what story is all about the
human heart in conflict with itself once
again
and you know one of the things that
pleases me no end is that I have so many
women readers and that they they do
write me all the time and say they
really like my female characters so that
I am very pleased with that